hi i'm merle and today i'm going to tell
you why i make zero waste tasty videos
tasty has a huge presence on the
internet so i feel a little responsible
for the content that we put out there
and i think we should be cognizant of
our impact on the world
we get into habits when it comes to
cooking and we get them everywhere from
our grandmother our dad tv you name it i
wanted to encourage people to think
differently about how they cook maybe
get a little crazy try something new
i think the term zero waste comes with a
very high built-in expectation
but think of it more as as close to zero
as you can get
some waste in day-to-day life is just
unavoidable but as soon as you start
thinking sustainably it'll spread to
other areas of your life and the people
around you will start to catch on too
that's how you can create change i'm not
as concerned with food waste as i am say
plastic because it's organic and can
naturally decompose when composted
you can get really creative with the
ways you use extra parts of vegetables
the stalks of broccoli and cauliflower
are jam-packed with nutrients and the
tops of leeks are full of flavor
challenge yourself it could be fun and
maybe you'll find a new recipe that you
absolutely love
i'm not the only one who's done
sustainable content ari has been doing
wonderful content for years and i'm sure
you all know ray has done some really
cool zero-waste challenges
i'm like who doesn't love rea
i'm sorry that i'm not rea if you cook
at home you probably know that you don't
always use every single part of the
vegetable this video is inspired by
something i do at home myself
i keep a little bin in my freezer where
i collect any food scraps that i produce
throughout the week every week or two i
have enough scraps so that i can make a
fresh batch of vegetable stock if you're
not buying your own vegetable stock
you're saving money you're cutting back
on over packaged goods and you can
control the flavor
one of the number one comments i saw in
this video was people saying to make
sure you wash your vegetables so it's
not like a trash soup when you make the
vegetable stock like yes definitely wash
your vegetables even if you're not
making vegetable stock you should wash
any fresh produce that you get and once
you have your veggie stock make sure to
compost your scraps to be a hundred
percent waste free my brother nathan is
the one who told me that this was even
possible in the first place so i owe
this success to him thanks nate after
that video proved to be a success i was
like okay so there's an audience here
how can i
take food scraps and make them work for
people even more let's regrow some
vegetables this video is another good
example of encouraging people to use
their food scraps instead of throwing
them away
and similar to the veggie stock video
you actually get free food from doing
this one of the top comments i noticed
was that people were saying they wish
they had more room in their home or
their apartments or that they had a yard
so that they could actually regrow their
own food of course most of us can't grow
all of our food at home but you can grow
some of it the whole point of this video
is that you don't need a yard if you
have one window with just a little bit
of light you can probably grow most of
these things in this video
the food we eat travels from all over
the country and in some cases all over
the world to get to us how nice would it
be if you had just a few things growing
in your very own kitchen a lot of people
tell me they kill every plant they own
and you know what i've killed plants too
it happens it's part of the process some
of them are gonna bite the dust but in
the end it's so worth it
scallions grow like weeds seriously if
you just clip off the bottoms and put
them in a little bit of water those
babies will be sprouting in no time if
you try to grow scallions and nothing
happens
you should move out of your apartment
because it's probably haunted
learning about how much food waste we
produced was making me feel a little bit
hopeless and i hate that so i was like
this is what i'm gonna do show people 10
easy ways to help the environment in day
to day life
plastic is a huge part of this plastic
bags plastic bottles plastic wrap
utensils straws
everywhere
only around nine percent of plastics are
recycled so if you're thinking it's fine
to buy overly packaged goods because
you're going to recycle it
you're better off just not using the
plastic at all luckily there are plenty
of reusable alternatives to all of those
things
pick the ugly produce just do it it
tastes the same other people are a lot
less likely to pick it and then it's
gonna go to waste
utilize your freezer if you have fresh
produce that you think is just about to
go bad toss it in the freezer you'll
give it a much longer shelf life another
really easy way to make your produce
last longer is to store it correctly
tomatoes and peppers are two things that
i am always pulling out of my friend's
refrigerators make sure you look up what
things should go in the refrigerator and
what things don't need to go in the
refrigerator this will improve both the
shelf life and the taste of your produce
i recognize that going zero waste or
even just reducing waste is a privilege
in itself it's not something that's
available for everyone and unfortunately
overly packaged and overly processed
foods tend to be the cheaper options
getting fresh produce can get expensive
so all you can do is the best you can do
finally i think it's time we start to
talk about composting okay composting
may not be the sexiest thing in the
world but bear with me it's very very
simple i'm gonna break it down for you
the composting effect happens when you
mix nitrogen-rich waste with carbon-rich
waste basically green stuff and brown
stuff after a few months the compost
will break down into really
nutrient-rich soil that you can use in
your house plants in your garden or give
away to friends and neighbors the
compost bin that i use at home is a
small countertop one and it has a carbon
filter in the lid so you can't smell
anything if you don't feel like having a
compost bin on your counter you can
always just freeze your food scraps and
drop them off at the nearest compost
receptacle
over time landfills create anaerobic
environments for breaking down matter
these oxygen-less environments break
down organic matter using
methane-producing bacteria that methane
is then released into our environment
contributing to global warming
so when you compost at home or when you
drop your food scraps off at a
composting facility you're ensuring that
your personal waste doesn't contribute
to greenhouse gases and instead can be
recycled back into the earth
i understand how overwhelming it can
feel when you think about the state of
our environment composting is a really
easy way to do your part
see if you can bring the practice of
composting to your work or your school
or your home
that little change will make a big
difference and it's an easy way to
become more waste free and
environmentally friendly in your
day-to-day life
i genuinely believe that most people are
good and that they want to do good but
you can't expect people to turn their
lives upside down just because you say
they should or i say they should a more
constructive way to get your point
across is to state the problem offer
easy and approachable solutions and make
it clear what people have to gain from
doing it if you do that and you don't
give up you can absolutely make a change
make sure you subscribe to good full for
more sustainable tips and recipes and
ways to try to save this planet
you